you have to look back at the one one
movie that you're most proud of oh I
know that's hard I I don't know proud I
don't know what proud means less than
zero that was a terrible experience I
did not enjoy that at all
um well I was in a bad place in my life
everyone was a script was a mess that I
didn't think that was a successful movie
um and then we had to reshoot so much of
it because it was right in the middle of
Nancy Reagan just say no era suddenly
and you know we had scenes with flushing
cocaine down the toilet because the
studio Executives realized oh this movie
is being made about our kids no we can't
have the you know and there's not a word
of the book in the movie and stuff so
you know that movie particularly you
know Bobby Johnny was great but he was
also you know a little too close to home
for him in that moment in time so well
he wasn't that easy because he was going
through it well he was lovely but he was
just going through whatever he's going
through he's always been a very sweet
guy you know
um
so but no that movie didn't fight I I
say I have great affection for Weekend
At Bernies I think somehow Jonathan
Silverman yeah he's great Johnny's a
great guy great and you guys look to be
so much fun in the movie I remember when
it came out it was just so hilarious and
so original yeah no I think it's great I
think when's the last time you've seen
it and have you watched it with any of
the uh well I can shamelessly tell you
that I was in a hotel about a month ago
and I flipped on the TV and I went into
the bathroom as I told you and I started
hearing this voice I'm like what is that
and I went back in it was me and weekend
and Bernie's and I watched like the last
it was the boat scene of chasing Dan so
I watched like the last 20 minutes of
the movie and it's a smile oh dude I'm
not even smiling I was sitting there
siding the lines back to the TV alone in
my hotel room and I can't remember ever
watching a movement of mine like that uh
ever and it was so and I thought it was
absolutely hysterical I thought it was
great I think every I guarantee I put
everything I have on it that every actor
has set back by themselves and watched
something of themselves and just had a
smile or a moment oh yeah but you know
for decades I could never watch any of
my movies ever but I was so I it was
either incredibly narcissistic or
healthy when I was watching one laughing
at myself thinking how funny I was
I love that is there is there a song
from any of those do you hate hearing
those songs when they come up no they're
great I mean I hear that like OMD with
now OMD yeah yeah yeah um and that from
Pretty in Pink that song right and then
the one I hear seem to hear in the
supermarket or wherever all the time is
the mannequin where nothing's gonna stop
us now they used it on the skeleton
twins with uh Kristen wig and everything
you don't want to hear that song no I
mean I just don't always have such a
Cheesy song but people love it
and what song I heard recently I hadn't
heard in years was to say now almost
fire you know man in motion song which
is just such a a cringe you know as my
son would say yeah yeah yeah and it's
that's just so of a moment you know some
of those songs are really endured and
like become part of the popular culture
yeah you know but that one I think is
just such like of that moment that it
just brings you right back